everybody listen this is important I'm
going to show you guys something and
when I show you what I'm going to show
you don't freak
[Applause]
out I can
[Music]
explain It's Beginning to Look a Lot
Like Christmas high stakes as neighbors
compete for best decorated house on the
Block I think this is the house to
beat it's my what's your Christmas
wish I just want to win this
[Music]
thing I'll take
it signature please ignore all the fine
print it's like you're signing your life
away Merry Christmas yeah Merry
Christmas oh it will
[Laughter]
be R and shine Naughty
Boy what the hell is all of this
something's happening good morning sir
are you real we all were until we fell
into that El's sck
trap you made your wish you're in it now
I didn't sign on for this you literally
signed on for this you got to read the
fine print man the terms are service and
brutal say goodbye to your
dad why y'all just like
Prince we are not going to let her turn
your Dad into one of those weird Happy
Meal toys no offense I'm sorry none
taken a little
taken we are the
Carvers we got to catch an
elf you met with the wrong
family we should split up what do you
mean we should split up have you never
watched a horror film if you split up
somebody dies have you ever died no it
is not fun that's true I've never died
but Mom knows I didn't know you got
before let's go find these
[Music]
Rings is that who I think it is oh my
God black S I knew Santa was black
[Music]
man